herr schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema afghanische
frauen in todesangst die radikal
islamischen taliban sind zurück in
afghanistan und seitdem ist das leben
vieler menschen dort in großer gefahr
und in kabul in der hauptstadt werden
nun demonstrativ und aber auch im ganzen
land die nationalflaggen eingezogen denn
die taliban haben jetzt selbst die
hauptstadt wieder unter ihrer kontrolle
20 jahre nach dem ende ihrer
schreckensherrschaft kontrollieren sie
nun wieder das leben von afghanen und
afghaninnen
am flughafen der hauptstadt
dramatische szenen denn es gibt keine
linienflüge mehr und raus geht es nur
noch mit der hilfe von ausländischen
militär und hier klammern sich menschen
verzweifelt an ein startendes flugzeug
und viele werden das land nicht
verlassen können kanzlerin merkel hat in
einer pressekonferenz heute auch auf
diese furchtbare entwicklung aufmerksam
gemacht und auch eben besonders für all
jene die sich für frauenrechte
eingesetzt haben und das ist heute unser
thema dann besonders viele frauen und
mädchen fürchten jetzt um ihre
sicherheit und viele haben sogar
todesangst und vor allem eben auch die
die er sich immer wieder kritisch
geäußert haben und für die rechte von
frauen gekämpft haben und die sind nun
untergetaucht teilweise oder verstecken
sich
und unter der letzten taliban herrschaft
hat man eben frauen so gut wie gar keine
rechte und da sind jetzt eben die ängste
sehr sehr groß dass das jetzt also
wieder so sein könnte und wir haben
medienberichte auch von frauen die ihm
versuchen aus angst zu fliehen weil sie
angst haben zwangsverheiratet zu werden
oder eben auch ich würde gerne in einem
tweet hier mal zeigen es gab eine einen
tweet hier auch aus herat einer
afghanischen stadt wo eben schon darüber
berichtet wird dass also frauen nicht
mehr erlaubt wird die universität dort
zu betreten oder eben auch ihnen hier
ihre ihre jobs das schon weggenommen
werden sollen also sie da ausgetauscht
werden sollen also die angst und die
sorge ist groß und das wird eben heute
unser thema sein wenn ihr fragen
kommentare oder anregungen habt dann
schreiben sie uns wie immer gerne per
mail oder kommentiert einfach im stream
bei youtube facebook wo ihr unterwegs
seid und wir wollen heute also sprechen
einmal mit unserer reporterin julia hält
die vor ein paar wochen also eigentlich
vor zwei monaten noch im land war unter
viele mutige frauen getroffen hat die
sich also da stark gemacht haben für
frauenrechte und mit magdalena kirchner
sie ist die leiterin des büros der
friedrich ebert stiftung in afghanistan
und wir wollen jetzt zuallererst
gesprächen mit der mit der aktivistin
pastor natura nie live in afghanistan
und pacha hat jahrelang mit ihrer
organisation lernen in afghanistan für
die rechte von jungen mädchen gekämpft
auf ein recht auf bildung und auf ein
selbstbestimmtes leben und letzte nach
dass sie eben selbst aus kandahar aus
ihrem zuhause geflohen an einen anderen
ort im land hat alles zurücklassen
müssen und pasta ich bin wahnsinnig
dankbar dass du heute mit uns sprichst
und dieses gespräch möglich gemacht hast
hallo
hallo vielen dank dass ich hier dabei
sein darf also ich bin vor paar tagen
aus kandahar geflohen nur dass ich das
richtig stellen darf alles klar ja
richtig und sie hatten da ihm alles zu
rücken lassen müssen und vielleicht
jetzt erstmal auch die frage dass das
die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
verstehen warum mussten sie kandahar
verlassen warum war das für sie dort
kein sicherer ort mehr
jetzt ist möglicherweise die verbindung
oder wir hören sie ja ich glaube jetzt
sehe ich sie und hören sie auch
vielleicht noch mal die frage also wieso
war kandahar für sie auch kein sicherer
ort wie so mussten sie den verlassen
in der vergangenheit habe ich immer
auf jeden fall mehr gehör verschafft und
deswegen gab es sehr viele kontroversen
mit den taliban auch aufgrund meiner
familie musste flehen meine
familie war ja immer gemeinsam mit mir
bei dieser mission unterwegs und auch
meine mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
die haben mit mir zusammengearbeitet und
ich möchte keinen dieser freunde und
familienangehörigen gefährten
und wie ist die situation jetzt gerade
heute abend in afghanistan da wo sie
sind also wie fühlt sich das jetzt
gerade an was hören sie vielleicht auch
von von ihren nächsten und von denen
mädchen und frauen mit denen sie
gearbeitet haben
wir alle als mädchen und frauen haben
angst wir fühlen uns unsicher wir
erinnern uns ja noch an die
horrorszenarien der vergangenheit bis
vor so einer stunde haben wir dann auf
einmal gehört dass die taliban
sicherstellen dass die frauen in büros
weiterarbeiten dürfen in kabul und das
auch in den gesundheitsberufen weiter
gearbeitet werden darf als frau jetzt
müssen wir mal gucken ob das wirklich
stimmt doch ob das vielleicht nur für
die gesundheitsberufe aufgehalten wird
auf jeden fall verlieren die frauen sehr
viel hoffnung die haben auch hoffnung
auf die regierung verloren und haben
einfach angst dass sie all das verlieren
was sie der vergangenheit hatten jetzt
unter den taliban das würde das denn im
schlimmsten fall bedeuten also was würde
im schlimmsten fall ein leben unter den
taliban für die frauen und mädchen im
land bedeuten
also wenn wir uns mal anschauen was die
so in der vergangenheit gemacht haben
mit
frauen so sehen wir jetzt schon dass die
frau nicht zurück an die uni konnten in
harald auch in kandahar durften die
frauen nicht weiter in der bank arbeiten
schon jetzt auch in den letzten vier
fünf tagen ist das passiert dass die
taliban die frauen zum beispiel nach
hause geschickt haben aus den banken
dass sie dort nicht mehr arbeiten durfte
oder dass die studentin nicht mehr auf
den campus dürften jetzt müssen wir
gucken dass
jetzt wirklich auch von denen umgesetzt
wird was sie so propagiert haben
gegenüber der internationalen
gemeinschaft sie haben gesagt sie würden
es frauen gestattet zu arbeiten das
müssen wir erst mal abwarten ob sie da
ihr versprechen halten aber ich habe
angst
für die
mädchen und frauen und sogar männer
haben jetzt angst jeder hier hat angst
jeder
und bevor wir gleich weiter sprechen
hören wir jetzt vielleicht mal auch ein
paar stimmen noch von anderen frauen in
afghanistan
die haben wir eingesammelt die ihre
ängste und befürchtungen dort schildern
und haben sie denn jetzt eigentlich
zurzeit überhaupt noch kontakt zu ihren
studentinnen also können sie die
erreichen oder haben sie die jetzt
vielleicht auch einfach schon tagelang
nicht mehr gesprochen
aufgrund unserer politik nehmen wir
keinerlei kontakt mit unseren
schülerinnen auf ich habe versucht mit
der rektorin kontakt aufzunehmen und
auch mit den anderen lehrkräften ich
habe aber nicht geschafft alle 18
lehrkräfte zu erreichen da mache ich mir
sorgen und die meisten leute die mit den
schülerinnen zusammenarbeiten die habe
ich erreicht und wir haben aber diese
große unsicherheit die hier vorherrscht
und alles prägt wenn es möglich sein
wird wirklich sicher zu sein dass die
frauen weiter arbeiten wann wirds da
eine sichere aussage geben und werden
wir wirklich sicher sein und was sind
die nächsten pläne der taliban
das ist eine absolute sicher situation
der unsicherheit und die leute verlieren
ihre hoffnung und wir wissen einfach
dass die taliban natürlich in der
vergangenheit sich schrecklich gegenüber
mädchen und frauen verhalten haben und
deswegen können wir ihn nicht trauen und
wir versuchen kontakt zu halten mit dem
schülerinnen und mit unseren lehrkräften
um sicherzustellen dass sie sicher sind
wir wollen sicherstellen dass es ihnen
gut geht das ist für uns ganz ganz
wichtig und man braucht ja auch
schülerinnen und lehrkräfte damit ein
land überhaupt gedeihen kann und
florieren kann und jetzt machen wir uns
eine große sorgen um die zukunft um
unsere ziele um unsere vision unsere
träume denn sie haben jetzt mehr
wirklich schon seit jahren auch dafür
gekämpft und haben sie jetzt so ein
bisschen aber auch das gefühl dass jetzt
ihr kampf ein stück weit auch ein
verlorener kampfer oder sagen sie schon
sie haben eben noch die hoffnung auch
ihre arbeit wieder aufnehmen zu können
an irgendeiner stelle
also ich bin kämpferin ich verliere
keine kämpfe wir werden natürlich nicht
geboren um kämpfe zu kämpfen darauf
dafür kommen wenn ich auf die welt wir
wollen nicht kämpfen müssen aber wir
lassen uns nicht entmutigen und unserer
bereitschaft besteht weiter den mädchen
das recht auf bildung zu gewährleisten
und nur weil die regierung jetzt auf
einmal beckenrand ist renne ich nicht
auch weg ich halte fest an diesem ziel
den mädchen bildung zu verschaffen und
das ist deren bedürfnisse und das möchte
ich sicherstellen
wir hatten eben gerade bei den stimmen
die wir uns anhören wollten von den
frauen und mädchen aus afghanistan ein
kleines übersetzungs eine übersetzungs
lücke und jetzt würden wir gerne noch
mal reinhören und auch diesen stimmen
jetzt noch einmal ganz kurz hier einen
platz in der sendung geben und dann
sprechen wir weiter
all go basiert sollte sich die situation
weiter verschlechtern und wir nicht mehr
arbeiten können haben wir keine andere
wahl als das land zu verlassen und alle
zu suchen
wenn es so weitergeht in afghanistan
dann wollen wir wieder us truppen um uns
zu unterstützen und mit waffen zu
versorgen
wir wollen unser land verteidigen wie
schon unsere familienmitglieder die wir
im jahre lang krieg verloren haben jetzt
sollten wir als afghanische frauen zur
waffe greifen und kämpfen ich habe keine
angst vor den taliban unser volk wird
nicht in die dunkle vergangenheit
zurückkehren ich bin eine frau und bin
von niemandem abhängig nicht von
pakistan nicht von amerika das ist mein
land auch wenn sie mich heute noch töten
sie sind mir egal
ich habe angst davor getötet zu werden
ich bin mir sicher dass ich hier nicht
überleben werde
hier im westen wann tatsächlich viele
überrascht dass selbst die taliban
tatsächlich so schnell dann doch das
land übernommen haben wie ist das denn
für sie wenn machen sie denn für die
situation auch so ein bisschen
verantwortlich dass die jetzt so schnell
so eskaliert ist
nämlich das ganz ehrlich sagen meine
regierung ist dafür verantwortlich also
die ehemalige regierung die wahren
korrupt und die sind dafür
verantwortlich die haben alle
hilfsgelder genommen den war die
bevölkerung egal
die hätten sich um die bevölkerung
kümmern kümmern müssen die hätten
sicherstellen müssen dass die leute
wirklich auch geld bekommen bezahlt
werden für ihre arbeit und dafür schlage
ich die afghanische regierung an und
dann natürlich auch dass die
amerikanische regierung die anderen
westlichen länder sichergestellt haben
dass eben nicht getan wurde um die
menschenrechte der mädchen der frauen
sicherzustellen dass die doha gespräche
nicht zum erfolg geführt wurden also
diese gespräche hätten auch über solche
menschenrechtsthemen verhandeln müssen
oder selten gar kein
verhandlungsgegenstand sein dürfen das
hätte sicher sein müssen dass
menschenrechte nicht verhandelbar sind
also zwei leute klage ich an meine
regierung die sind korrupt die denken
nur an ihre eigenen ämter und möchten
keine gute administration schaffen eine
gute verwaltung und dann beschuldige ich
aber auch die anderen westlichen länder
das ist da bei dem doha
verhandlungen keine fortschritte gab und
dass die taliban ebenso wieder an die
macht gelangen konnten
und was muss passieren vielleicht eben
auch international also was muss
passieren dass das ihnen wirklich
geholfen werden kann also was sehen sie
da was fordern sie was muss ganz ganz
dringend jetzt gemacht werden
druck ausgeübt werden auf die taliban
dass die das recht auf bildung von
mädchen anerkennen für alle möglichen
lehrfächer die in unseren schulen in der
vergangenheit bis heute
unterrichtet wurden außerdem muss auch
die möglichkeit gesichert werden dass
frauen weiter arbeiten dürfen das muss
gesichert werden nur weil die regierung
ist eine neue ist darf das recht den
frau nicht verwehrt werden und die
internationale gemeinschaft darf nicht
vergessen dass wir weiterhin finanzhilfe
brauchen auch für die bildung für
kapazitätsaufbau für infrastruktur
entwicklung
erstmal muss druck ausgeübt werden auf
die taliban dass die politischen rechte
die rechte auf bildung die rechte auf
ein angemessenes leben gewährleistet
wird und die internationale gemeinschaft
darf uns nicht verlassen
sie müssen uns weiter unterstützen und
wir müssen das land weiter aufbauen das
ist sehr viel wichtiger als dass man
jetzt einfach das land den taliban
überlässt
vielen dank bastian oranier für den mut
und auch die zeit die sie uns setzt
geschenkt haben in dieser ganz
besonderen situation wir denken an sie
und bleiben sie bitte sichern
vielen dank auf wiederhören
wir sprechen jetzt in dieser sendung mit
zwei weiteren frauen zum einen mit
magdalena kirchner leiterin des büros
der friedrich ebert stiftung in
afghanistan jetzt an einem sicheren ort
neben nicht mehr in afghanistan und mit
meiner kollegin julia hält die noch vor
zwei monaten durch afghanistan gereist
ist und afghaninnen getroffen hat die
eben in den letzten jahren für freiheit
gekämpft haben wir fangen mit ihr an
julia die zunächst einmal vielleicht wie
geht es diesen frauen heute die du noch
vor zwei monaten in afghanistan vor ort
treffen konntest die lage hat sich
natürlich extrem zugespitzt in den
letzten tagen und auch die nachrichten
die wir bekommen sind wirklich super
dramatisch also ich muss echt zugeben
dass ich bis vor ein paar tagen mir
eigentlich vor allem um die frauen
sorgen gemacht habe mit denen wir in
herat gedreht hatten schon als wir da
war war ja klar dass die taliban nur
noch etwa 100 kilometer von der stadt
entfernt sind und die frau mit der wir
gedreht hatten war klar sie steht auf
der todesliste sie hatten nachrichten
gezeigt oder die taliban ihr geschickt
hatten da waren bild zu sehen von dem
mädchen dem sie die haut abgezogen
hatten gesagt hatte du wirst genauso
enden wenn wir wenn wir dich finden und
als dann in den letzten tagen oder
letzte woche klar war dass sie hier rat
erobern werden war für mich klar oder es
war klar das sie dann wirklich
tatsächlich das nicht überleben würde
sie hat mir dann tatsächlich eine
nachricht geschickt dass sie es
geschafft hat raus aus der stadt sie ist
in den iran geflohen tatsächlich auch
das unter todesgefahr und habe von dort
an weiterhin geschrieben und den
nachrichten geschickt die es wie es in
herat weitergeht auch total dramatische
nachrichten die familien wurden
aufgefordert alle mädchen die älter sind
als 15 jahre an die taliban zu übergeben
also es war es wirklich eine
katastrophale situation dort und man
muss auch sagen dass sie im iran die
lebensbedingungen für afghanen in iran
einfach auch keine keine guten sind sie
können dort nicht arbeiten mädchen oder
kinder dürfen auch nicht zur schule
gehen also sie hat mir auch von dort
wieder geschrieben dass sie dass sie
lieber zurück gehen möchte und als als
ein flüchtling als als geflüchtet im
iran zu sein und auch das gefühl was sie
hat das gefühl hat dass ihre familie
dass sie ihr land im stich gelassen hat
ist für sie ist ein ganz ganz akutes und
ganz dramatisches oder sie wirklich
tatsächlich konkret darüber nachdenkt
zurück zu gehen und mir geschrieben hat
lieber tot und lieber in den händen der
taliban als als geflüchtete und als eine
als jemand der sein land im stich
gelassen hat und dann erst also um
unsere protagonistin in kabul die
fotografen mit der wir gedreht hatten
ich habe ich mir tatsächlich eigentlich
wirklich keine großen sorgen gemacht wir
haben vor ein paar wochen als wir da
waren wir noch zusammen getanzt also es
war wirklich eine vollkommen andere lage
sie hat mir vor drei tagen noch
geschrieben dass sie sich um die
geflüchteten in kabul kümmert dass sie
den in essen bringt und denken und dass
wir sie dabei begleiten können dass wir
sie filmen können also sie war noch sie
war vollkommen fühlt er sich vollkommen
sicher und hat auch gesagt dass sie bis
zuletzt dort bleiben will und auch sie
hat gesagt sie würde lieber in kabul
sterben aber jetzt tatsächlich seit
gestern nachdem diese gefahr jetzt
wirklich so konkret ist sind die
nachrichten die sie mir schreibt
natürlich auch vollkommen andere und sie
sagt sie hat todesangst sie versucht
alles sie bittet uns um ihr zu helfen da
raus zu kommen und sie sagt wenn die
taliban finden sie finden oder
rausfinden wo sie ist dann wird sie das
nicht überleben
frau kirchner sie haben die letzten
jahre in afghanistan gearbeitet ist das
ein beispiel von vielen das was julia
gerade geschildert hat
ich würde sagen zurzeit schon also ich
habe auch von ähnlichen also ähnlich
berichte auch gehört aber wir sind
natürlich auch wir arbeiten hier mit
vielen jungen menschen auch mit frauen
aktivistin aus den provinzen wie jetzt
nach kabel sind eigentlich wird sicher
sein wollen aber
jetzt eben angst haben dass sie
vielleicht auch von verwandten oder von
taliban jetzt bedroht werden und jetzt
gerade große schwierigkeiten haben auch
sichere unterkünfte zu finden weil die
sicherheitslage in kabul extrem prekär
ist
wir haben hier fragen natürlich auch
ganz viele und kommentare bei uns im
chat und ist es einmal liana lena auf
youtube die fragt was wollen denn die
taliban von den frauen und julia was
haben denn jetzt zum beispiel die frauen
die du getroffen hat es auf seiner reise
was haben die denn getan wenn man das
überhaupt so sagen kann um aber zur
zielscheibe von den taliban zu werden
ja das ist ja das was ein so vollkommen
fassungslos macht die frau die wir in
kabul begleitet haben eine fotografin
eine junge fotografin
fotografiert fotografiert vor allem
mädchen junge mädchen sie reißt das
ganze land um mädchen ein gesicht zu
geben wie sie sagt weil sie das gefühl
hat oder weil sie seit das dass frauen
nicht nur keine stimme haben in diesem
land sondern eben auch kein gesicht
haben und sie will ihnen wieder mehr
rechte geben und sie mehr sichtbarer
machen und fotografiert deswegen vor
allem eben mädchen und gerät dadurch
tatsächlich ins blickfeld oder auf die
auf die zielliste der der islamisten das
man man kann sich tatsächlich kaum
vorstellen die frauen mit den rad
gedreht haben die haben eine
organisation gegründet eine kampagne er
ist mein leben heißt die und da geht es
darum auch das etwas was wir uns hier
überhaupt nicht vorstellen können sie
haben für das recht gekämpft dass der
name der mutter in den ausweisdokumenten
in den geburtsurkunden der kinder steht
es ist tatsächlich so also es ist eine
tradition was sie sagen ist dass frauen
wenn sie älter werden dass der name auf
geburtsurkunden auf todesanzeigen auf
grabsteinen einfach nicht auftauchte
steht dann immer nur mutter vom vater
von tochter von aber der name der mutter
viele söhne viele kinder kennen den
namen ihrer mutter tatsächlich nicht und
sie sagen der name ist ein teil genauso
wie die bilder oder wie die gesichter
der mädchen der frauen das ist etwas
womit womit frauen auch eine ein
selbstbewusstsein bekommen
beziehungsweise sie verlieren ihr
selbstbewusstsein dadurch gelöst dass
sie nicht mal ihren namen wirklich
nennen dürfen und tatsächlich ist das
problem also man muss sich das mal klar
machen dass wenn eine wenn der name der
mutter auf dem geburts dokument nicht
steht ganz viele väter sterben sind
nicht da gehen sie ins ausland die
mutter hat keine rechte ihre kinder an
einer schule anzumelden oder sie eben
ins krankenhaus zu bringen oder eine
arztbehandlung einzufordern das ist dann
zum teil so dass nachbarn onkel
großväter irgendwelche anderen männer
kommen müssen um das irgendwie
anzuordnen weil die frauen keine rechte
haben und das ist das wofür sie kämpfen
sie haben tatsächlich auch ein erfolg
erzielt im letzten jahr hat der
afghanische präsident ein neues gesetz
unterzeichnet das dieses dass dieser
name auftauchen kann in dem dokument
aber die taliban haben sich haben klar
gemacht dass sie das nicht wollen haben
hier ganz klar immer wieder nachrichten
geschickt dass sie diesen kampf
unterlassen soll
diese ängste der frauen die kommen ja
nicht von ungefähr die kommen daher dass
eben in den 90er jahren unter dieser
schreckensherrschaft der taliban also
schon einmal das leben für die frauen
sich radikal verändert hat frau kirchner
können sie dazu vielleicht noch ein
bisschen auch einordnen für alle die
darüber noch wenig gehört haben
vielleicht was ist denn damals im
prinzip passiert wie mussten frauen denn
damals leben ja also ich glaube es ist
auch wichtig was vorhält gesagt und auch
frau dora nie vor uns selbst in der
phase die wir jetzt hatten also seit
2001 ist jetzt eben zur rückeroberung
afghanistans durch die taliban haben
frauen auch eine wirklich schwere zeit
eigentlich in afghanistan also es gibt
sehr viele vermieter es gibt sehr gewalt
gegen frauen
zugänge von frauen zur bildung zu
gesundheit werden als eine krone krise
gesehen es gibt eben noch viel was im
argen liegt und wo sich etwas verbessern
werden muss jetzt ist es natürlich die
frage mit in taliban wird das schnell
nicht passieren und wir sehen aber auch
das ist eben eigentlich in allen
dimensionen des projektes frauen am
meisten leiden habt also beispielsweise
und vor den kriegsopfern sind
überdurchschnittlich viele frauen kinder
jetzt die unsicherheit wir haben wie
viele frauen eben jetzt auch vertrieben
wurde nicht wie auch gesagt wurde ohne
ihren mann gar nicht das kind aus dem
band also ich hier gibt es eine grosse
unsicherheit und selbst und kunst wie
war das vor 2001 gab einen ganz
interessanten ist bewusst einigen
monaten weil man sich dann auch erinnert
an die zeit als taliban das letzte mal
nach afghanistan
nachkommen sind und sie kamen in einer
phase die zum teil noch viel
schrecklicher wahrgenommen wurde nämlich
ihr absolut recht beschreibt wo es zu
sagen milizen bürgerkrieg gab kurze und
vergewaltigungen und morde und die
taliban ist geschafft haben mit einer
sehr brutalen herrschaft eine art von
ruhe wenn auftritt buchs uhr wo einst
also ein zurück und unter den taliban
ich glaube dass die jungen afghanen am
meisten zeit
verbinden ist einerseits natürlich
einschränkungen von mobilität also man
auch nicht aus dem haus grund angezogen
akram also ein
begleiter
da oder den vater ihr mann man hat
einigen chance selber aussuchen was mein
beruf machen möchte prüfe den frauen von
vornherein student erlaubt große treiben
mitbestimmung und was die reben
natürlich auch das symbol vielleicht
auch wenn das vielen teilen afghanistans
auf weitere burg war und ich bin diese
totale bescheid
ja sagen ausdrucksfreiheit ihre frauen
das haben vor allem die frau darauf
geschrieben wurde auch in den letzten
jahren anders erfahren und das ist
natürlich sehr schrecklich wenn man sagt
freiheit schon einmal genoss wie ich
jetzt wieder bei der das zurück
eigentlich leisten kann und wird alles
an die meisten ja auch was die
gesellschaft aber wenn ich jetzt keine
möglichkeit mehr haben erstes werden
lehrerin werden und auch vorreiter
entwicklungen wechselte preisfragen dann
ist das natürlich für den meisten
brammer
julia sehen denn die frauen mit denen
nur kontakt hast du auch immer noch
kontakt hass säen die dann überhaupt
eine chance für sich gerade
zurückzukehren ist das überhaupt für die
irgendwie im bereich des möglichen in
nächster zeit
also es ist für mich ganz schwer das zu
beantworten und ich glaube auch dass
wenn man sie persönlich fragen würde
dass sie darauf keine wirkliche antwort
hätten es ich habe es vorhin ja schon
gesagt oder wir wissen sie alle die
situation erinnert sich hier gerade
minütlich und auch gestern
hätten da hätte man ganz viele es nicht
für möglich gehalten also ich kann ich
traue mir da nicht wirklich eine antwort
darauf zu
und hättest du das kommen sehen als du
da warst dass sich das so schnell der
die lage drehen könnte du hast vorhin
gesagt er warte noch tanzen sogar also
ihr habt zusammen getanzt als du da
warst hast du das gesehen hat sich das
so an gefühlt als du dort war es vor
zwei monaten ist es lustig weil wir
tatsächlich führe ich ja in letzten
tagen auch viele derartige gespräche und
ganz viele hier die sagen das war doch
vollkommen klar und das hätte man doch
kommen sehen müssen und so naiv konnte
man doch gar nicht sein und so ich
hab es nicht kommen ich hätte es mir
nicht vorstellen können dass stand immer
im raum
es war diese diese diffuse sorge die
taliban haben schon ein großteil mehr
als 50 prozent zu dem zeitpunkt des
landes eingenommen an territorien an
bezirken eingenommen und kam im prinzip
auch während wir da waren haben wir
immer so ein meldungen bekommen und kann
im prinzip jeden tag kamen höhere
distrikte dazu die wieder neu
eingenommen wurden und trotzdem blieb es
liebe ist sehr abstrakt und wie es
gesagt habe es gibt wie immer in diesen
ländern natürlich gibt
bereiche an denen gerade die menschen
mit denen wir da eben gedreht haben die
für einen sehr westlichen lebensstil ja
auch eintreten die sich freiräume
schaffen an denen man dann in den
momenten auch wirklich sie überhaupt
nicht vorstellen kann dass die
eingeschränkte werden könnten also es
war für mich auch wenn ich die ganze
zeit mit namen mit zu mit sondern
bedrohungsgefühl aber das war jetzt
nicht konkret auf die taliban bezogen
mehr da hat man natürlich angst vor
terroranschlägen und so weiter es war
für mich nicht vorstellbar
danke julia held dass du diese erfahrung
und seine eindrücke und auch das was du
jetzt eben gehört hast noch mal mit uns
geteilt hast danke dir und bevor wir mit
frau kirchner jetzt vielleicht auch
gleich noch mal ganz viele von euren
fragen aufgreifen was bislang noch ein
wenig zu kurz kam hatten ein wo es noch
mal für uns zusammengefasst wer die
taliban eigentlich sind und was ihre
ziele sind
steinzeit islamismus so erinnert die
welt dass afghanistan der taliban in den
90er jahren ein reich der finsternis
ohne musik und filme ohne frauenrechte
ein land in dem öffentliche
hinrichtungen alltag waren solche
exzesse sind auch jetzt denkbar so
experten aber sie sind weniger
wahrscheinlich auf der anderen seite
haben haben wir auch die berichte der
entwicklungsorganisationen die ja sagen
sie arbeiten zum teil gut mit den
taliban zusammen weil die taliban
natürlich jetzt auch in der situation
sind dass sie liefern müssen um ihre
legitimation innerhalb der bevölkerung
auch zu erhöhen haben die taliban also
dazu gelernt ihr vergleichsweise
unblutiger sturm auf kabul spricht dafür
es gibt bis jetzt noch keine berichte
darüber dass es zu massenverhaftungen
massen erschießungen lassen
misshandlungen von
regierungsmitarbeitern von streitkräften
gekommen ist die sich ergeben haben
bislang geben sich die kämpfer eher
zurückhaltend denn rachsüchtig
und in denen bereits eroberten provinzen
können frauen und mädchen weiter zur
schule gehen allerdings müssen sie ins
tor tragen also dieses dieses schwarze
gewand was hat nur das gesicht freilässt
endlich in iran
aber das ist ja schon mal ein zeichen
dass sie zumindest schulunterricht also
hoffen sich die sekundar unterricht zu
lassen ob es dabei bleibt hängt vom
machtkampf innerhalb der taliban ab ob
sich die fundamentalistischen feld
kommandeure durchsetzen oder die eher
moderaten taliban gruppen die verhandelt
haben
[Musik]
wir haben nun einige fragen im streamen
die sich jetzt auch ganz grundsätzlich
noch mal mit fragen zu den taliban
beschäftigen ich bin mir sicher da gibt
es natürlich viele fragezeichen hier bei
uns und zwar möchte hier tobias lese
gerne wissen wie groß ist die
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz der taliban
in afghanistan
die schnelle eroberungen lässt er eine
große unterstützung vermuten oder ist
das eher auf angst basiert was würden
sie dazu sagen frau kirchner
ich glaube das ist natürlich schwierig
festzustellen in dem land wo es jetzt
keine richtigen umfragen gibt aber wir
haben eigentlich aus den letzten jahren
als sieben befragung auch durchgeführt
wurden für die einstellung haben sehr
viele menschen
sich eigentlich gar nicht also angesagt
wir können uns schon verständnis der
regierung auch die taliban beinhalten
könnte sie haben sich aber immer
ablehnend gegenüber der gewalt gezeigt
und wenn die taliban eben nicht
sozusagen mit krieg an die macht kommen
dann gab es da gar nicht mehr so viel
widerstand ich glaube wir sehen jetzt
dass die taliban versuchen eben diese
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz wenn auch
sozusagen im nachhinein einerseits zu
schaffen also sie sind sehr vorsichtig
und diplomatisch auch wie sie jetzt in
kabul auftreten und haben auch im
vorfeld eigentlich sehr viel wert auf
verhandlungen und eben also dass
menschen die sich dann ergeben dass eben
auch nicht alle erschlossen werden
sondern parteien seien sie zeigen sich
eben auch versöhnlich ich denke wenn es
keinen rückhalt in der bevölkerung geben
würde konnte man sich das natürlich
nicht erklären aber das land ist wie
gesagt jetzt auch einigermaßen überrollt
worden von den ereignissen vielen wissen
auch noch gar nicht so richtig finde
jetzt nur für unsere kontakte auch in
carol sprechen was sie eigentlich zu
erwarten haben ich glaube die taliban
profitieren vor allem davon profitiert
dass die menschen von der regierung
einfach so enttäuscht waren und eben
denken na ja also wenn die regierung uns
nicht beschützen kann dann müssen wir
natürlich irgendwo selber dann auch
kompromisse schließen und die taliban
geben vor allem das angeht was für viele
das größte problem war nämlich eben eine
unkontrollierte gewalt
was ebenfalls rechtlosigkeit auch
verstehen und die taliban sind da eben
für einige zumindest bringen sie eben
eine gewisse stabilität wieder ins land
jetzt gibt es stimmen die sagen die
taliban design moderner geworden was
bedeutet das überhaupt moderner und hat
das dann vielleicht aber auch andere
auswirkungen wie schätzen sie das ein
sind das andere taliban heute als die
die wir das vielleicht auch im beitrag
zuvor gesehen haben
ich meine auch damals ja natürlich
andere zeiten also man merkt natürlich
schon dass man wenn man das bild hat von
taliban verbieten musik und und machen
fernseher kaputt und heute sind sie auf
twitter und und geben videonachrichten
also natürlich haben sie sich auch vor
einem technologisch der zeit angepasst
und sind da auch also sie haben eine
sehr starke kommunikation und sind jetzt
nicht also zumindest auf der
führungsebene viele sprechen ja auch
englisch und wissen auch wie man sich
sozusagen zu benehmen hat um auf dem
internationalen parkett und sprechen
auch die sprache sie wissen schon auch
was sie sagen müssen wenn sie mit
internationalen sprechen also von daher
würde ich sagen was das schon es wirkt
sehr professionell was das mit den
einstellungen natürlich zu tun hat ich
meine das ist natürlich eine andere
frage
bis jetzt habe ich noch nicht den
eindruck dass die taliban sich eben
dahingehend verändern dass sie jetzt
eben auch bewusst also beispielsweise
westliche oder sich die was eben die auf
der republikanischen seite als
errungenschaft angesehen wurde also das
eben frauen zum beispiel zur universität
gehen dass sie sich dass jetzt auch die
fahne schreiben das scheint ihnen jetzt
aber auch noch gar nicht so wichtig zu
sein also sie sind auf jeden fall
moderner sie sind strategisch extrem
veh ich also zumindest zurzeit auf der
höhe der zeit und ob sie sich von den
inhalten auch verändert haben das liegt
natürlich auch an der gesellschaft aus
der sie stammen wir sehen schon dass die
taliban dort wo sie biete unter ihre
kontrolle bringen wo die bevölkerung
beispielsweise die bildung von frauen
sehr wichtig findet dass die taliban
dann manchmal sogar eben auch schulen
über das grundschulalter auch erlauben
und dann nicht aus prinzip die die
schule abbrennen aber wenn sie in
gesellschaften kommen und dann gebiete
in afghanistan ist eben auch gibt wo die
einstellungen der gemeinden noch wie
konservativer sind wenn sich nach nicht
dafür einsetzen also ja sie sind moderne
sind effektiv aber sie werden sich jetzt
haben sich sozusagen noch keine moderne
agenda gesetzt sondern es geht vor allem
um die basalen
basalen grund services die sind jetzt
sehr wichtig
und dann richten sie sich eigentlich
schon nach dem nach den gesellschaften
in denen sie sich jetzt eben in der
rolle der herrschenden finden es wird
sehr spannend sein das haben wir auch
vorn gehört mit herz und den konflikten
wie wird es eben sein wenn die taliban
große städte kontrollieren müssten wo
frauen ist vielleicht nicht akzeptieren
wieder unter den tschador zu gehen da
wird es dann glaube ich schon noch mal
spannend wir haben auch hier in
deutschland bei vereinen organisationen
nachgefragt wie sie jetzt glauben wie
sich dann in carrier ihre zusammenarbeit
jetzt mit den menschen vor ort für die
sie sich einsetzen wie die sich
verändern wird und nadia schier vom
afghanischen frauen verein hier in
deutschland hat uns erzählt wie sie also
nun künftig versuchen wollen kontakt zu
halten in diesem neuen afghanistan und
vermutlich dieser taliban-herrschaft
die gespräche laufen über die eltern das
läuft über unsere dorfältesten über die
es gibt bestimmte gruppierungen von den
eltern die in dem dorf leben die dann
kontakt aufnehmen und vor allem durch
das erziehungsministerium von der
afghanischen regierung die mit denen
wiederum in kontakt kommen es ist so wie
wenn sie auf einer straße gehen dann
fliegen sie 20 meter nach vorne und dann
wir stehen dann fallen sie auf die nase
dann blutet ihre nase dann werden sie
zurück geschleudert so sind auch mit
unseren projekten wir müssen mit allem
rechnen wir müssen hart bleiben
kontinuierlich bleiben für die menschen
bleiben für die zivilisten bleiben und
so ist die entwicklung mit den frauen so
kann ich das ihnen bildlich da schon
anders ist das wirklich sehr schwierig
und zukunftsszenarien zu sagen das kann
man ganz schwierigen auf ganz dann sagen
wir haben noch mehr fragen von euch im
stream marco frederik hat bei facebook
schaut uns bei facebook zu und möchte
gerne wissen da bezieht sich jetzt
wieder auf die taliban also wieso die
taliban überhaupt solche versprechen
machen haben sie sich so sehr verändert
also da kommen wir noch mal zu der frage
wirklich ob sie sich verändert haben und
er fragt frauen dürfen arbeiten ich bin
echt baff über die letzten tage also
auch hier nochmal in user der sich sehr
wundert ob und wirklich nochmal fragt ob
das jetzt tatsächlich
anders werden könnte da vielleicht noch
mal ne kurze einordnung von ihnen dazu
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen selbst
wenn ich mit leben meinen mitarbeitern
in kabul spreche die sind auch
also baff wie das jetzt auch gesagt
wurde weil es eben manche dinge gibt man
sagt man hatte sich das wenn die taliban
nach capo zurückkommen eben vielleicht
ganz anders vorgestellt es gibt ja auch
weniger also wenig erfahrungswerte in
anführungszeichen die meisten afghanen
wurden ja nach 2001 geboren aber
ich glaube wie gesagt es hängt schon wir
haben noch keinen sehr klares bild also
wir sehen eben in manchen städten ergibt
das dann irgendwie reibungslos es wird
jetzt sehr spannend weil die taliban die
regierungsmitarbeiter aufgefordert haben
wieder in die büros zurückzukommen es
wird auch eine große frage sein ob man
vielleicht auch wieder banken
zum laufen bringt und da arbeiten sehr
viele frauen mehr als in den provinzen
arbeiten in kabul in der verwaltung
natürlich auch frauen und bis jetzt
wurde noch nicht gesagt zumindest meiner
meinung nach also meines wissens nicht
dass die frauen dann nicht mehr zur
arbeit können also das kann schon sein
dass man sich eben dann pragmatisch
zeigt aber natürlich wie gesagt sie
wissen eben auch wie es welche bilder
sie jetzt in die welt schicken die
taliban versuchen sich international
legitimieren ich glaube nicht dass die
jetzt denken es wäre für sie eine eine
kluge entscheidung jetzt eben wirklich
martialische
praxis wieder einzuführen so lange sie
eben nicht die tanzformation wieder her
also ihre macht wieder eingestellt haben
und die anerkennung der nachbarstaaten
bekommen haben bis jetzt hat man schon
den eindruck dass sie da sehr behutsam
vorgehen und sich schon bewusst sind
dass sie da auch unter beobachtung
stehen
trotzdem viele menschen wir uns am
anfang gesehen versuchen das land zu
verlassen also wirklich schlimme szenen
am flughafen wir haben es erwähnt sie
konnten das land verlassen sind an einem
sicheren ort wie war dass wenn ich dann
noch mal fragen darf also wie war das
für sie konnten sie noch gut raus und
wie ist das vielleicht aber auch noch
für leute die sie kennen die noch vor
ort sind
ja also ich muss natürlich dazu sagen
als ich im juni das letzte mal da war
und ist für uns schon länger immer eine
frage gewesen wie viel kann man jetzt
kann man den carbo sein ich bin
eigentlich sehr oft außerhalb des landes
und als ich nach hause kam jetzt im juni
war es eigentlich dort noch relativ
ruhig wir hatten schon seit april große
sorgen um die zukunft des flughafens
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit den
bildern die wir jetzt heute gesehen
haben sondern die frage wie der weiter
betrieben werden kann und das ist
natürlich für uns ein riesen problem
wäre wenn dieser flughafen erschließen
müsste und deswegen war es für mich
ehrlich gesagt eine ziemlich man hat
schon gemerkt mehr leute sind ausgereist
also mehr leute ein versuch das land zu
verlassen der flieger war schon sehr
voll und auch mit mehr gepäck aber es
war eigentlich noch eine relativ normale
normale zeit ich denke das ist überhaupt
nicht zu vergleichen mit der situation
in der jetzt viele sind dass sie auch
das telefon starren und warten dass sie
einen an oft bekommen ob sie es auf
irgendeinen der verschiedenen
evakuierungsflüge
schaffen die nicht wissen ob sie auf dem
weg zum flughafen gleich einem
checkpoint stecken bleiben also ich
glaube so möchte wahrscheinlich niemand
also für mich ich möchte niemals
natürlich so reisen müssten aber auch
die menschen die jetzt eben ihre heimat
und ihre arbeit und ihr leben
zurücklassen müssen ist es natürlich
jetzt extrem dramatisch
bevor wir zum ende kommen vielleicht
noch die frage so ein bisschen was ihre
einschätzung auch ist wie es jetzt
weitergehen könnte also was gibt es da
für szenarien vielleicht kurz
zusammengefasst
also jetzt werden wir natürlich erst mal
abwarten müssen was jetzt wie sich die
situation in den kabel- und in den
nächsten tagen ergibt die signale bisher
sind eigentlich also vor allem was
dieses verhalten den nachbarstaaten
angeht und auch trotz sozusagen der
aussagen dass man jetzt die taliban also
sich genau anschauen würde wie die
taliban sich jetzt weiter verhalten bis
man über die frage der anerkennung
spricht ich glaube das könnte wenn jetzt
sozusagen nichts wirklich schief geht
für die taliban eigentlich ziemlich
ziemlich gut laufen natürlich wird man
darüber sprechen müssen was für eine art
von verfassung oder staatlichkeit es
dann geben wird wie man sich auch einig
mit den ehemaligen machthabern von denen
auch einige auch im land sind aber ja
die lage ist sehr fragil also es kann in
alle richtungen eigentlich noch
ausschlagen weshalb die teile waren eben
auch versuchen jetzt schon auch die
häuser zu durchsuchen zu entwaffnen um
eben zu verhindern dass es eben in kabul
zone noch brenzligen situation kommt und
dann werden wir natürlich über die
ganzen fragen wie die taliban eigentlich
das land regieren sprechen müssen
afghanistan durchlebt gerade eine extrem
schwere dürre es gibt hunderttausende
binnenvertriebene in der stadt das noch
humanitäre katastrophe und die taliban
haben bis jetzt natürlich eigentlich nur
den alpen verwaltungsapparat auf den
sitz stützen können und dann wird man
eben genau diese dinge auch noch mal
angucken müssen über die wir gesprochen
haben also welche möglichkeiten können
den die taliban
überhaupt dann auch frauen und natürlich
auch männern eigentlich bieten welche
angebote können sie machen dass die
menschen vielleicht auch im land bleiben
wollen und sich quasi von einer
kriegsparteien eine regierungspartei
verwandeln das ist ein extremfall jeder
prozess am mittwoch natürlich ein
bisschen sorge ob das reibungslos
funktionieren kann aber wir können jetzt
eigentlich auch alle nur auf sicht
fahren
ich möchte ja noch eine letzte frage aus
dem stream auch gerne aufnehmen und zwar
sehr ag möchte wissen was kann man denn
für die frauen oder ganz allgemein für
die menschen in afghanistan von hier aus
thun bei all den schrecklichen
nachrichten fühle sie sich sehr hilflos
ja das kann ich auch verstehen und das
gibt's also das geht mir genauso und ich
glaube vielen
ich persönlich denke wir müssen
natürlich sagen deswegen jetzt sehr
viele leute das land verlassen aber es
sind auch sehr sehr viele menschen im
land jetzt auch eigentlich unsere hilfe
und unterstützung fast noch mehr
brauchen aber auch natürlich menschen
die jetzt geflüchtet sind und in eine
unsichere existenz also das heißt man
kann auf jeden fall spenden und
initiativen unterstützen die es eben
geflüchteten leichter machen schutz zu
finden und vielleicht auch sich eine
neue heimat aufbauen zu können in
afghanistan gibt es noch sehr viele
humanitäre organisation die man
unterstützen kann natürlich ist das
vielleicht ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein aber das ist eine sache wo man
weiß bei die monetäre krise eben im land
geht ja weiter und wenn wir jetzt diesen
den einsatz abschließen und dann ist der
abzug droht natürlich auch dass das land
gleich wieder vergessen wird aber die
probleme der menschen beiden da ich
glaube dass es eine kleine sache die man
tun kann und eben natürlich auch
menschen mit dem man eben ein kontaktes
mut zusprechen dass sie eben sich nicht
alleine fühlen oder also das ist
vielleicht eine sache die ich jetzt tun
sehr oft tue aber die vielleicht
natürlich auch andere menschen tun
können die mit afghanen kontakt sind und
eben auch deren stimmen und geschichten
auch weiterhin zu erzählen ich glaube
das ist die größte angst der
afghanischen frauen da sehr viele
afghanischer frauen noch aktivisten dass
sie eben verstummen und dann niemand
mehr eben sich für ihre geschichten
ebenso sicht der dinge
interessiert und sie keine möglichkeit
mehr haben selber für sich zu sprechen
und ich glaube das ist was was wir
natürlich auch im ausland weiter auch
befördern können
wir wollen auf jeden fall weiter an dem
thema dran bleiben an diesem abend für
den moment jetzt hier erstmal vielen
dank an sie frau kirchner für ihre
einordnung und für ihre zeit und
natürlich auch vielen dank an euch für
eure aufmerksamkeit für euer interesse
für eure fragen und kommentare und wir
werden natürlich auch noch in den
nächsten tagen das ganze thema
afghanistan und mit all seinen problemen
weiter im blick behalten
bis hierhin erst mal tschüss macht's gut